>> Hi YouTube. I would like to answer to Freesouljah.
I agree absolutely with what you are saying
and I wanted to ask you if you have ever looked
at Wikipedia. I joined that project six years
ago and I joined because I wanted to communicate
with others and work with others. And what
I discovered is a place where people recreate
communities and they work together to create
content and make this content debateable to
all the other ones. And what is very interesting
to really join this community would discover
that many of our editors are very young people.
We have people as young as 14 years old. We
have many 17, 18 year olds, so they could
be my children. And they teach me a lot of
things and whilst they add content to Wikipedia
not only do they feel empowered to do it and
teach others what they know but they also
learn from others. And they learn a lot of
new skills such as, collaboration, they learn
how to deal with others, different people
from other nations and all other countries.
And this is an absolute great pleace for them
to discover life. So I would really suggest
that you go have a look and maybe try to lead
some children to join Wikipedia. So that's
it. Thank you.